sie sieht so aus wie die letzte der aus
wie noch nie die haben auch 2 bringen
will kommen sie kommen sie konnte kommt
es ja
hallöchen freunde willkommen zurück beim
einkauf minecraft 2008 soll total
durcheinander weil ich mich total darauf
freue weil hier steht jedes steak clay
kombibau das mal ab jetzt geht's los
zeigt jetzt geht's los ich bin sowas von
bereit kommt können die grüne bereit
ich will nach oben das zweite moment
bist du wirklich bereits wenn so
bereiten möchte wissen was du wirklich
wirklich bereit weit kommst du
vollkommen bereit
dann fällt ihr bereit für den letzten
block moment komplett complete ok läuft
wieder doch oben gelaufen
katzenpsychologen was bringt uns den
hinweis nicht erst mal kann man die
werte 90 hey du musst du musst von den
ganz weit weg sein und dann musst du mit
dem fisch dich ganz ganz langsam an sie
näher und so langsam guck mal wie ich
bin
das mache ich jetzt wo man ihm geht auch
ein gebratener fisch nee da muss rosa
stimmt erich engel du hangeln wir mal
angel in meinem team bleibt gleich und
jetzt wird wieder es wurde wieder holz
freigesetzt hier oben durch um seinen
erfolg den wir gerade erzielt haben mit
der oem wochen merklich mehrere von
denen dings von dem was von den fischen
für die noten oder brauchen wir nur
einmal braucht eigentlich nur einen für
den oslo dann verwandelt er sich immer
zur kasse
guck mal da oben noch zwei erfolgen wir
sind bei der nächsten tour da oben und
unten ist autofrei gesetzt weil da
wollen wir auch noch gleich hin durch
nehmen erst mal ganz kurz das ganze holz
hiermit damit wir uns auch so ein
bisschen vorrat haben weil ihr wisst ja
holzes
wow ist relativ wichtig es braucht schon
wieder ich hab gleich im fisch glaube
ich glaub ich hab ja wir können uns
jetzt einen gang machen von oben nach
unten
echt jetzt ich glaub da habe ich mit
meiner folge mit den ranken oder mit eng
mit leitern leiten
wir sind schon weiter hier sind schon
leitern aber du bist ganz unten
doch fast bis ganz nach unten echt wie
schon mal commander cooper bis kann aber
nicht bis juli kennst dann weiterbauen
nach oben an die leitern ja stimmt ja
stimmt wir können nach unten das weiter
vollenden mit denks noch mit ranken
genau wie ganzer wald mit den massen
holzen auch in china schon hier unten
weiß dass ich dadurch an jedoch nicht so
sich darunter fall aber ich habe auch
ein bisschen angst auf der anderen seite
herunter gebaut oder wo man sich schon
mal ganz gut ich bin runter gefallen
habe ich lebe doch ok ja das sieht ganz
gut aus da oben ist vielleicht noch rot
gefärbter ton und dann gehen wir auch
mal gleich an die kiste rande
und weil da freue ich mich auch drauf
was es wolle dieser skala japan
was ist wurde dieser kiste drin wir
können uns schon mal name überlegen für
die katzen meine katze nämlich maut sie
alter das ist ein richtig guter name
aber maut ist eigentlich aus sie ist
eine maus ich nenne als pikachu pikachu
ist die katze eine maus ist eine katze
dem haus diese katze pikachu war die
maus das hat ja noch fünf katzen
ich nenne meine hottie the nottie ist
ein schöner name renault pilot und lotti
darüber und loggia oder das ist echt
cool
wir haben einen tag aber vielleicht ist
das nur ein die ab den wir waren uns
auch erst mal vielleicht ist er für ein
pferd später wären eine vertröstung ich
habe keine ahnung was ja eigentlich
etwas bringen wo er wenn wir ein
fertiges werde auch ich jedoch gleich
wieder zu den pilzen und holen das war
zu viel fisch lachs ich habe hohen lachs
ich ahne weiter ich bin einfach wie
viele level hast du ich habe 16 level 16
ich habe elf das geht bei beiden ganz
gut nur bei denen bayer wenn man tempo
gehalten so ein bisschen und
ausgeglichen
okay ich mache jetzt mal hier wieder so
ein paar sachen rein damen in rot
gefärbten ton in sankt moritz
wir haben auch schon wieder ganz viel
holz sachen wir haben jetzt wirklich
mehr als 1 des holz das muss jetzt
endlich mal sagen endlich das ist ja so
krass war wieder ich habe glaub ich hab
noch ein fisch für dich ganz hoch kommt
ok ich nehme noch so ein paar mal mit
also wir bauen in china werden nach oben
und diese leiter ist echt coole wir
müssen die vielleicht wenn man noch so
viele zäune aus dem ding oben dann
können wir mal so ein bisschen
einzuholen
alter ist nämlich gefährlich weil wie
komme ich jetzt tue was ich angegeben
schnell noch einen fisch wenn jetzt noch
einer kommen dürfte tanzen zu sehen
welche erscheine ganz viele blogger
bläschen halter ist das cool emotion
zloty
achtung ich glaub ich heute weiblich und
männlich das wäre ein traum
so jetzt acht und neun jetzt noch ein
fisch plötzlicher wegen dem roten lack
ab
wir müssen uns ganz weit weg stellen von
denen russische wo ist aufgebaut sie
keine ahnung wie sie können wir müssen
aber aufpassen wir müssen ganz weit weg
kommen hierhin kommen ganz weit weg der
einig würde vorstand nicht gleichzeitig
einfach mal zuerst ich mal ganz langsam
ganz langsam
der müsste mich gleich sofort sehen
eigentlich und dann guckt er zur rolle
der andere geht hier auf die leiter
gucken sie sehen mich beide an aber ich
nehme nur ein ok weg geh weg geh weg
hallo ich dort doch ehrt herzen ein und
herzen aber der weg gelaufen vielleicht
noch mehr fische okay ich probiere ich
mein glück wollen wir mal tauschen
vielleicht verwandelt er sich gerade
eine katze denn keine ahnung komm ich
probier's mal geht man da oben hin oder
so ja ich gehe mal ganz weit weg hier
ich gehe mal hier in weitere kann ich
nicht kommen
er ist sich aber dann macht das kaum im
club auch immer dagegen im fisch auf
frauen zu in der 80
du musst die anderen nehmen die kam auch
gerade durch andere wobei her wo ist der
andere dies hinter dem dieb haben gerade
die kommt gerade da für mich dann
bewegen nicht ob gar nicht nehmen muss
warten bis sie auf die zukunft und damit
auch kein erinnern jetzt doch doch doch
doch doch er macht herzen sie macht
setzen und meine komplette kommt auch
geradezu mir gelaufen sind jedoch nicht
sie noch wieder weg bitte die machen gar
nicht sich doch die verwandeln sich
direkt dachte ich auch angel noch ein
bisschen alter und er will wieder
weglaufen von mir ich hab dem noch
karten fisch gegeben
ich mache erst mal ganz gut dass unsere
leute hier so ein bisschen sicherer ist
haben wir da nicht noch so ein bisschen
jahr 24 200 das doch super man schade
schade ich angle jetzt einfach mal heute
wollte ich mal du kannst ja aber nie
alleine möchte ich auch nicht und
schicken das mana gleich zusammen wie
bitte manchmal ein wenig ausbauen und
ich mache gerade eine zaun leiter auf
die andere seite von der leiter damit
wir dann nicht runterfallen weiß um die
unsichere ist kannst auch den tunnel
doch bayer leiter noch weiter nach unten
bauen wo wir dann halt die rentnerin
machen
stimmt das kann man so ist aber richtig
aufpassen da waren so und runter fallen
ja ich muss mal ein bisschen gucken hier
oder da habe ich jetzt auch 22 habe dann
ist die leiter auf jeden fall schon mal
so ein bisschen in dem 20
meine katze hat sich zu mir nach unten
teleportiert ich glaube die mag mich
doch echt ja die muss ich nun mal
verwandeln ich glaube dir auch noch mehr
fische aber guckt jetzt guckt mich an
jetzt kommt sie wieder weg gelöst wie
jetzt habe ich mich einmal schnell
bewegt der haut direkt ab nach oben wenn
ich das noch stirbt die läuft in der
höhle die sonne kommt ist über die tür
gesprungen
diese sogar nach oben schnell bevor die
noch nach unten rente die sie die
hoffentlich habe ich hab mir mal die tür
aufgemacht ich musste das jetzt gerade
mal
ach so viel sport gemacht die firma zu
von bleibt für immer unten in der höhle
online bei den monsters schnell mal vor
wir haben eine katze dann können wir die
höhen gehen und die kripo max für uns ja
wann die dann nämlich mosley nicht mit
denn ja es stimmt das ist mir noch nie
wert wie für schuldner als pächter
hostie gerede vom hörer immer noch in
der 40
jeden tag hier auf hitze noch gut ab sie
lockt die loks elf die mit namen copa
data pack jetzt mal eben auch noch
welche nicht dass wir da irgendwie aus
versehen mal runterfallen ich glaube
inzwischen ist ein teil ist eine
wichtige quelle für fische aal diesmal
also muss das alter kommt fisch kommt
mir vor ich bin ganz ruhig du hast
ich habe ihn okay war es nicht schwer zu
greifen zwei fische für eine katze
guck mal ich hab mir leid anhin gemacht
also ganz falsch eileen fischer da sagt
rommel
das madrider 53 stück habe ich schon
natürlich erst mal die katze dazu klären
wenn ich zu der ikb endlich zu der
hingegen lasse eigentlich mal was machen
die ich heute eigentlich wann wie geil
ist überhaupt dieser teil von captain
minecraft legendär
ich hoffe es komme ich glaube an den tag
kommt schon wieder global bisschen ofcom
jetzt du schaffst das jetzt ich
beobachte von ganz weit hinten von der
leyen ich habe mich sehr bewegt egal ich
immer in die ecke
ganz langsam noch langsamer und jetzt
einfach warten
ganz langsam hin bis sie sich angucken
dann einfach stehen beim und gepflegt
bleiben jetzt jetzt stehen dann oft mich
ein stück sich an sie kommt didier cuche
ja aber sie gemein die realität sieht so
aus wie nazis oder aus wie nordsee kreis
rechten bild von dir und mut zu machen
spox war nicht mal eben auf 20,27
möchten bild von ihren mut zu machen
wie geht das so komisch ankommen
der guckt aber nicht dass knuffig kommen
uns eine katze die angel mein sohn öle
die schalotte halb fertig die scheiße
lotti sondern erhöhen
sehr richtig
ich wäre fast runter gefallen als das
ist doch nicht so ganz sicher was auch
mit der leiter erich hole mal unseren
base heute grüne augen irgendwie krass
mit ganz toll wo ist dein lotti und otti
botti bot sie da ist sie richtig feiern
du ja durch feine besitzt da kam mir die
ecke kommen
wir kommen partie kommen der lotterie
wir wollen wir den challenge katzen
abschleppen
hänni macht immer aber ich habe sie
schon mal nach oben gelockt ich hab sie
nach oben gelockt dieser moment herzen
übersät guck mal du musst jetzt wieder
ab in die höhle da unten aber sie kommt
da nicht lange sicht so jetzt kommt sie
da nicht hin
ok jetzt gehen nur ein stück immer ganz
weit weg gen westen hoch oder so lass
mich mal mit meiner leute alleine
es komme jetzt kommt didier und daher
nach oben
ich bin soweit sich jemand wirklich
einer dass ist das eine folge man will
doch gar nicht um die kiste und ich hab
auch zwei dingen wie kommt sie kommen
sie kommen sie kommt ja ja das ist eine
richtige lot alter kann sein dass du
dich liebt olivia katzenkinder er trinkt
komme und ich geb dir gleich schwimmen
macht mal rechtsklick auf die wieder mal
eine ecke bleibt ich habe hier in meiner
ecke meinem auf sie und du hast du deine
deine holidaycheck.de lockt die comcom
mit hasan fischteiche vielleicht holen
sonst ja so kritisch geblieben man die
sein zimmer kommen jedes mal ein
ihr motto jetzt sucht sie die hat also
runter geguckt noch die kommen über du
schaffst das kommt ihr land sie kommen
sie konsequent sie kommt kukksi geht sie
geht zum platin ist schon dort sind sie
kommen mir leisten
komm lass ich mal dahin setzen ich hoffe
brauchen fisch um die zusammen zu
bringen und dann haben wir wie nennen
wir das kind können die zuschauer
schreiben den kommentaren
aber so weit sind wir noch gar nicht mit
kindern und so manche müssen sich erst
mal kennenlernen erstmal freunde werden
das machen wir in ein paar folgen mal
alter okay und ich würde sagen sätze ich
dachte man noch die auch hin weil die in
irgendeine katzen ecke machen weil meine
katzen ecke bauen jetzt von uns allen so
jetzt guckt sie wir nicht in guckt doch
nach fortis ein richtiges hohen viel und
schlug auf der kommt das stück auf eur
gerne wieder
ja in meiner erfolge hier wieder diese
lotina jetzt jetzt jetzt ziemlich
geschubst
ist das geil das wurde mir willst das
schön
ich kann das nicht so groß wie damit
also älter aber lasst sie wirklich wenn
wenn die stirne ich beende das projekt
sofort bei mir aus trauer alter nimmt
ihnen müsste alter die kann sich oft
kisten hinsetzen auf keinen fall mit in
die höhle mein mann kommt meiner meinung
meiner leute kommen aber zu deiner aber
hatte mal feldmann und eine hin etwas
nicht so hast du in lauf auch auf battle
gerne mal springen setzt das werk seien
immerhin mache ich nicht dass seine
rumläuft ich selbst auch nicht viele
leute mal hinter dem engel immer mal
monster wohin ich gehe jetzt mal eben
hier hin soll mein gott ich dachte
schule komme sei vorsichtig wir brauchen
auf jeden fall immer einen fisch um die
mitzunehmen umzuziehen so trotzdem kommt
sie tue dir nichts an ich gebe jetzt ein
bisschen holz für ein zaun aus
hätte ich nur ein fisch das wäre doch
mist hab keinen fisch mehr wir haben so
viel holz ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen
holz für den sound aus okay ich hab das
problem an den gebratenen fisch möchtest
du gebracht
nee möchte sie nicht so jetzt tue ich
das in den crafting table zwei teile
so haben wir sechs davon auf und packe
ich zwei nämlich hier dran
so jetzt schiebt die damalige da machen
wir da so ein kleines zaun tor hin
okay wir stimmen mehr zu holen und alles
dann packe ich damals im sound auch noch
hin
wiewohl krass so ist das auf jeden fall
merken dass wir noch an die trug sie mal
rein
so bekommen ja so und dann machen wir
dann immer noch schilder wenn wir genug
am auto und das mahngericht irgendwas
aufsteller die mia und auch immer so
schön wollte mal was kann man da mal hin
stellen die folge ist aber auch schon
wieder vorbei und wir müssen auch noch
die kiste angucken wo man das machen wir
dann alles in der nächsten folge bei
komme und ich würde sagen jetzt euch
gefallen hat wir an beide jeweils die
katz wir haben noch nichts erreicht
haben katzen das ist richtig cool man
vor allem den maut- sie sich richtig aus
dem aufziehen
das ist richtig und raumschaft lotti
habe ich mir wirklich so schwarz-weiß
vorgestellt irgendwie ist es richtig
brach richtig räumen ist alles super wir
haben alles erreicht alles klasse
noch keinen fehler gemacht glaube ich
wirklich sagen sie nicht noch nicht
vielleicht noch kommen ist voll gelaufen
wie die kiste und machen noch ganz viele
andere sachen und die folge kommen dabei
komme und dann will ich sagen immer
wieder schön locker rein und schön mit